Lạm báo một người binh quan ngủ đầy thử thách,
câm việc của đội vui phẩm viên nhà báo không chỉ đến thuần là Lưu Thin mà còn mang trên phai sướng này
như lại sự thật phản ngánh nghiệp thử,
có phần xây dẫn và bảo vệ tụ quốc mọi ngon của cố mềm.
Trong buồn vản xan khó của nề,
tụi thách lớn nhất,
thụ về những phong điện chính trường,
nghĩ ở dẫn thân đồ trứng đưa,
lửa dẫn trực tiếp ở hiểm duy để truyền tại sự thật,
tệ những ngon bong trời đạc là.
Họ, mong làm giúp cảm,
ý chỉ thế và tình yêu người mạnh liệt
đã được lý trình tất cả để triệu với lại từng khoảng hấp trên thực tục bộng của lịch sử.
Tụi đây, còn những tắt phòng báo chỉ đã ra đời
và sống máy với thời gian.
Nhà báo của trình máy hưởng,
nguyên tục giống lốc thung tình xả Việt Nam,
quà mua trung những phong điện chính trường dẫn thân người tính lừa,
tình góng ngặt tại những mặt trận khóc lịch,
cố vực đấu trang dải khóng dân tộc.
Tụi mù hề đò lửa năm 2019 tại thành cuộc khoảng trị.
Để những ngày sục sưu trên đất cảm ơn chiều khi trế độ dịch trường
bong bóng tất sục đồ.
Ông đại đi qua những năm tháng,
mà mỗi mức tranh đều có thể là răng giữ xin tự.
Tối đất tình,
bản nằm giữa bại bóng bây đồng hai,
chịu sự đẹp của mấy mắt đa sống sốt.
Hôm nay có nước thành quân đi qua,
các bạn bóng bí nổ chậm.
Cứ không biết khi nào nổ,
nhưng mà việc bình đi mình cứ phải đi,
bởi vì đều không đi,
bởi vì mình không thể có nhỏ khác được cả.
Bởi vì đó nó cũng về sự tử,
thế là căn thằng này mà tân nào thì mà mình có khó khăn.
Tất liệt trong năm tháng chính tranh đường tàn,
hình ả hết,
nhà báo trình má hưởng hiểu rằng
mỗi tắc phẩm ra đời trong thời điểm này
đều phải đánh đồ bọng mồ hơi,
nước mắt thậm chí,
cả tính mạc.
Có biết bao nhà báo đợi vừa quan lần tranh xin tự
để rử lại những khoảng khóc,
hình xử.
Tổ này luyên,
có điều cao trên bởi và
xin cái lên cao bằng tí xuống cốc bật phà không?
Ngày đêm,
tổ chào lên trên tí,
tổ nó trên xin cái là bộ đổi.
Mình nhắc là anh đứng lên trong,
anh ngồi xuống này.
Bởi vì,
nếu đứng lên bởi vì cái bản thẩn đó.
Nhưng mà mình có thể thắc điện với bây giờ
bởi vì nếu mình lên lên lên rồi,
mình không chồng,
mình không chào lên đây.
Bởi vì cho nên là mình là cái tắc cả,
thì rất là dân năng,
rất là có nhiều không,
là cái bân đàn mà mình phải chào lên tận trên đấy,
thì mới chúng được có cảnh vậy,
và bất đàn đặc tức mụ bí quế của bờ.
Lưa xuống phòng để trứng đầu khỏi lừa,
nhưng với nhà báo trần máy hưởng,
chưa này bà mưa khẳng gân gâm mình chỉ chăm bởi bây lâm,
là khoảng khắp không thể nào quên.
Thì, trước xe tăng xuống dựu,
tám bốn sống hút lộ công dân được lập.
Chúng khoảng khắp lịch sự này,
vời tinh nghiệp làm gì lâu năm,
sự nhân dậy,
sắc mẹn,
cùng với một chút này mắn,
ông đã có đuộc bất đắt phần báo chi sống mãi với thời gian.
Múc anh này,
đưa bố cuộc chặt trẻ,
anh sáng tự nhiên và tính biểu tượng cao
không chỉ nghĩ sống chiến thắng
mà có lăn tỏ tính thình mất quốc
khách phọng ngoài bị vật liêm hơn,
anh này đắt nước thông nhất.
Trong đỏ cố gần báo tương nghĩa là,
có nhảnh liên có cay nhảnh,
nhảnh rất ra đón,
nhưng trên sĩ đe có cả,
sẽ tăng có cả bộ bíng và cán lực lượng khác lửa,
thì khi và rý cơ giết,
giật tôi giới trong máy tré còn khoảng giám,
cái giám, cái giám, cái phí mà.
Thế vì mình khi mình vào khoảng cơ,
mình sẽ kia sẽ là tiến bào,
rất là đẹp thì mình rất mấy cái bị chung ngay.
Nhưng mà trong nấu là bất chình nghĩa là bếng một thuy ngành đẹp.
Và rất là đẹp chung.
Một cái lần nhảnh quá,
trên mình không lý là có thể là cảnh có bí có đá,
thì không đá,
và là phụng trụng với tôi,
là bố đón có cả báo bố tạo,
phụng trụng cảnh như tương tự,
có có bói và phụng bí tụng cái xe.
Trong này,
về rộng xe em lại trong tư lượng thì
của bạn của tôi là sao?
Bố qua đi cửa.
Thế còn kia bố gái của mắt tạo lực sẽ là bảo trong sân.
Từ là ra nó phà hồng thím của tạo lực.
Thế thì chính với thế mà của bạn,
tôi có nó biết được dùng giọng và gặp,
và đúng cái thời điểm.
Những người cảm buông tình để qua bóng đàn
điều mang trong mình một tình yêu này sông giá,
và chính nhận lưới nào với tổng quốc,
trong số ấy,
của nhà báo khái ruy,
một tự này đặc biệt.
Một cái buông bình bị gần tám,
với năm không bị người,
chính kiến và nghĩ là những bước hoạt lượng nhất của lực sự dân tập.
Ông năm 2018 đã trải có khá khăn chiến,
từ chính sĩnh địa binh phủ để chính sĩnh của chính miền,
có phần và nạn chung tự lượng sống chính trường
của nghĩ công cuộc kiến thiết nất nước trong hoặc mình.
Tắc phẩm, sống như anh,
cân chuyện vãnh của lực sĩnh ở văn chối ra chỉ phát thịt quyền,
một anh chối kỳ lại,
được ông đi lại dưới tên trình định văn,
đã trở thành quân sách của lối đầu của báo thế hệ,
với hàng chục trở mạng in,
từ vệ ra nhiều tự tiến trên thiết giới từ phái mạng rất nhiều lần.
Vất không phục,
kể kể kể kể kể ý chi,
và kể nghĩ lực lòng được vượt dịch khó khăn,
làm mà hó đảng mặt trợ như nhé báo thế hì.
Vết chất thịt của hóa mà tạc quyền đặc sắc nhất,
là vết một cái tắc phẩm lộn tiếng,
là sống như anh và gọi chối,
tất cả chỉ phán tri quyền.
Cũng có trò chuyện và chuyến tri phán tri quyền kể hệ rần.
Nhà báo thấy rộn làm việc rất cình mất,
rất chú trọng như vui trí tiếp để hình thành lật tắc phẩm ló chuyện,
mà không quảm gì lẽ hả khó hăn răng rồi,
thời gian mạng yêu cần phục lạ làm mắn rồi,
và trở trọng vọng đoạn này,
đã hoàn thành lật tắc phòng tất là kể sống dạng,
để quảm thành lũng thông kế hoàn.
Sau ngày dài phẩm,
nhé báo thấy suy công tác tại báo đại đoạn kết,
ông tích tục mạng mẹ chính đấu tuần sự nghiệp hoán mối bằng hàng chăm bài báo,
nó phần tạo những cuộc kết mạng trong đồng nghiệp.
Vào bình,
vào thay gì là tiếp tục dân thăng vào những vóng đề nóng báo của nóc lức.
Họ cũng để lại dì tắc phẩm rất là đến hình,
và rất là phó sức là tỏ như là nhiều rất tắc phẩm về phán.
Hãy những cái đế bàn nóng báo như 2 phòng.
Hãy lại như là 2 phần tuy nghĩ là các cái hệ,
nhưng nhà báo kể hình này,
thì có thể học tạm rất nhiều.
Ở, tôi là nóng không phải là nóng bây giờ tạm của tạm báo gái.
Nhưng mà ông là bộ phía nhà báo thực sử dụng tính,
nhà báo của những gì đó.
Nhà báo của những cái tắc lốc với lao rau.
Dùa, nó phía nhà báo của đại đầy báo này nó rất tất cả.
Dù phía như tạm ra, xin mạng, chỉ chỉ lấy.
B yeth đi của Bồ tôi là xong phàn, phong ánh của mình.
Cả đôi làm không biết mà ông rất tất cả lần.
Tại vì thích lật thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao là thử cao.
Chức đi gạ trị, không biết là, đi lạy để phàn hoàn.
Nhưng mà có rất mấy mạnh của đấy là nóng hòi hệ hồi hồi hồi hồi hồi hồi.
Tức tính, nó có hòa là xác của tôi.
Trời này tất líên là chúng thực đi, chính là hả mình, chúng tức cóng hòa hồi.
Mí u nhảm báo chính trường là những người đã trọn con đường không mằng phần, đó là hành trình với lứa triếp bóng đặt khiếm muý và thử thách.
Ở đó, một trong viết, mỗi quên hình, đường được đánh đồ đằng sự tấn thân, lòng qua càng, tình yêu nơi và tình yêu lứa sống sắc.
Có người nghĩ lại khoảng khác đất nước thống nhất mạo mỉnh, có người để lại những trang sách lấy đột lòng người qua hai cuộc khấn chiến, nhưng tất cả họ, điều chungu sứa mạnh,
mà sự thật đến với nhân dân, điều dự kiệu xin tộc mằng ngồi buốt và trái tin của mình.
Rửa dòng trái thử dòng, những tắc phần biết được trái tin thống đọt mất thử lịch sử,
vẫn sẽ sống mại, đó không chỉ là tư liệu cuy ra của đến máo chỉ cách mạng,
mà có lần mọi lua chuyên cảm hiến cho thế hệ là báo, không này, mại sao?